uh yeah thanks for having me my name is
uh robert i'm the cto of ask me and i'm
gonna uh tell you about the lessons we
learned from actually deploying machine
learning in cement and concrete
so basically my talk consists of three
parts so the first
i'm going to talk about the big or
massive problem that cement and concrete
has and then i'm going to introduce the
solution that we came up with and what
machine learning has to do with this and
then finally we come to the actual
lessons that we learned from deploying
our machine learning solution in the
wild
so let's start with the problem so
concrete is the most used building
material across the planet in fact the
only thing that mankind consumes more of
by volume is water and it's
just getting bigger because it's
expected that by 2060 the worst building
store will have doubled that means from
now until then every month we will
rebuild new york city that's good on one
hand because that means there's more
housing for an ever-growing population
and there's infrastructure for the
developing world but this comes with a
very heavy price tag and the big problem
i'm talking about is the massive carbon
footprint of concrete it's eight percent
of worldwide emissions so if concrete
was a country it would be the third
largest emitter right after china and
the us
and to understand where this carbon
footprint is coming from let's look at
how concrete is made so it all starts
with a quarry with a limestone quarry to
be precise and that's great because
limestone is available all around the
earth meaning it's available in these
huge quantities that are needed to build
the world so then this limestone is
transported into a cement plant where
it's refined into cement which is the
most important ingredient for concrete
then later on in the concrete batching
plant to the cement we add water sand
and gravel and then we have ready-mix
concrete which is transported to the
construction site to build bridges
houses you name it
and the carbon footprint of this
material is basically due to one step
and that's the cement plant and to be
more precise it's one particular step of
the cement production that is almost
exclusively responsible for this massive
carbon footprint and that is the cement
kiln or the rotating kiln it's where the
limestone from the quarry is taken
burned and turned into clinker clinker
is the stuff that makes the concrete
heart problem is if i burn limestone
what happens is that the co2 in the
limestone actually gets released into
the atmosphere and the important part
here is it's inherent to the process so
we can't mitigate the carbon footprint
simply by using renewable energy
so how can we then reduce the carbon
footprint
to get a better idea let's again look
back at the main ingredients of of
concrete so it's water some admixtures
like plasticizers sand aggregates and
the most important one the cement
remember cement is the one that has the
heavy carbon footprint if we look more
closely at the cement actually cement is
made out of just basically speaking two
things so one is the clinker that's the
stuff coming out of the kiln that's the
one that's really heavy co2 footprint
and the other stuff is basically filler
materials so called supplementary
cementitious materials some of them have
their own carbon footprint like fly ash
or slag which are byproducts of steel
and coal production but others like fine
limestone or also called limestone
flower are basically carbon free so
limestone flora is just limestone that
has been ground very very finely without
burning so no co2 emitted
so um basically the whole carbon
footprint of concrete is due to this
clinker component so a way to mitigate
or to reduce the carbon footprint of the
building material is simply to reduce
the amount of clinker in the entire mix
and that's actually what we want to do
so if this is regular concrete with
regular cement with lots of clinker we
can get to low carbon concrete uh using
low carbon cement which just has a tiny
or a short amount of clinker in it and
with this simple step we can actually
reduce the carbon footprint of concrete
on average by 60
and that's not just a pipe dream because
we've actually done it so we created
this low carbon concrete made loads of
tests in laboratories to see if it's
still a feasible material and we even
moved out of laboratories into a real
construction site so not long ago in
august we actually poured our first
concrete pour like in a real
construction site it's a foundation of a
garage to show that this low carbon
concrete actually works in reality so
that's great news low carbon concrete
exists it works you might question now
okay what does machine learning have to
do with this why do you need an i.t
company and machine learning to produce
that
okay so
as i said in order to reduce the carbon
footprint we want to reduce clinker the
challenge here is that clinker actually
makes concrete robust that means if we
reduce the clinker we get less robust
concrete
so any problems or intricacies that are
already happening in the cement
are then amplified by our low carbon
concrete and the most important property
of cement is its compressive strength
that's what's making the buildings
upright so if we have quite some
fluctuations over time in this
compressive strength these fluctuations
get amplified if we use low concrete low
carbon concrete recipes so one of the
big prerequisites for low carbon
concrete to be produced at scale is that
we have a reliable and trusty cement
strength um
and that's actually hard to achieve
because measuring cement strength takes
28 days
and the way you do this is you form
actually a concrete cube with cement
a standardized amount of water and a
standardized amount of sand and then you
have to let it sit for 28 days and
harden and then you crush it like this
after almost a month to figure out how
much compressive strength it can
withstand sorry here's now where machine
learning gets into the mix so we will
use machine learning to get or we do use
machine learning to get the cement
strength on point um so what we do is we
actually predict the cement strength
that would develop 28 days later right
at the time of production so we can
immediately counteract if something's
going wrong
so here's here's the principle so first
of all where do these fluctuations in
the compressive strength stem from well
cement is made out of a natural material
and that is limestone
and limestone might vary from cubic
meters to cubic meter even within the
same quarry so the chemical composition
and mineralogically can actually change
and these changes in the composition of
the limestone then yield changes and
fluctuations in the compressive strength
so what we want to do is basically just
counteract these compressive strength
changes by adjusting the fineness of the
material because the fineness of cement
is a good lever to influence the
compressor strength the more fine i
grind my cement and the more surface
area it has to go
to react with water the stronger it gets
so meaning if uh due to natural
fluctuation the cement gets stronger we
can actually grind more coarsely and if
it's getting not strong enough we can
grind more finer and with that
we then can achieve a material that has
a very reliable and homogeneous and
consistent strength over time
so
here's how our application actually
integrates into a cement plant what you
see here is a depiction of the last step
of the cement production the cement mill
so we are now right after the kiln
remember kiln produces clinker heavy co2
footprint but here are the other
supplementary cementitious materials
like fly ash slag and the carbon free
fine limestone so all so these get mixed
together according to your cement recipe
chucked into the cement mill to actually
grind them very very finely and then
there's this filter or separator step
that can separate fine particles from
both ones so the fines ones are finished
and then the coarse ones have to take
extra turns through the cement mill and
by influencing the separator and some
settings of the cement mold we can
actually influence the fineness of the
material but it doesn't stop there so in
a cement plant there are regularly
cement samples taken right after the
cement mill and these are automatically
analyzed with x-ray fluorescence x-ray
diffrectomy and a particle size analyzer
so um this gives us a characterization
of the
samples in terms of its chemical
composition crystal structure and actual
distributions of particles and this data
then is exported into our cloud ai
system
where we then run machine learning on
top of it to really predict the
compressive strength that would have
developed or will developed 28 days
later and now we can react immediately
and don't have to wait a month to figure
out how strong our stuff is going to get
so for instance if then we predict that
the cement is getting too strong we can
grind more coarsely if it's if you're
predicting it's getting not strong
enough we can grind more fine
actually what we do is simply compute
optimal set points for the cement mills
in order to achieve this and then these
set points are fed back into the plant
the cement is adjusted either by the
operator or directly by the expert
system in place and then when we draw a
sample two or three hours later we will
see okay we have uh reacted to the
changes and now the cement strength is
really on point again
and here's how that actually looks like
um in like how the results actually look
like that we achieved in the plant so
what you can see here our strength test
of a cement plant uh over about five
years and every blue dot here
corresponds to one particular strength
test where they actually formed such a
cube that i just showed in the video let
it sit and harden for 28 days and then
crush it
and as you can see um in this rolling
median function here that basically the
fluctuations are quite substantial over
time so
um the the fluctuations in the spend
strength go from like 50 to 65
megapascals and that's actually quite a
lot and now from here on as you can see
uh we applied our solution into the
plant um and we were able to reduce
these fluctuations by about 30 percent
um which then for an average cement
plants amounts to savings of around 300
to half a million euros and it's a
mixture of savings and energy savings in
co2 certificates and actually higher
profit margins due to better quality
so
basically this is the whole control loop
and the machine learning service that we
provide for cement
plans and we've deployed this now
in
four plans plans five and six are soon
to be coming but actually getting there
and having the whole system running was
quite a bumpy ride and we had some
learnings on the way and that i want to
share with you now so learning number
one or lesson number one is do not spend
too much time on complex models i mean
we tried many different machine learning
models and so because it's fun i mean we
tried pytorch neural networks i mean
deep learning is fun
you can play around with the network
architecture
you can play around with the learning
rate even the learning algorithm itself
test dropout you name it lots of stuff
to try out of course we try support
vector machines gaussian processes
xgboost you name it we tried it um
unfortunately all of these gave
basically no improvements even worse
they are quite black boxy models so what
we really ended up with in production is
a combination of regularized linear
regression and a random forest for the
non-linearities
that's actually great because just
looking at the coefficients of the
linear regression you can really
understand what the model learned from
the data and that's actually important
because we deploy our models in order to
really control cement life
meaning we have to be confident that the
models not only picked up some spurious
correlations between the features and
cement strength but actually learned
causal
causal relations that are also known to
smed engineers
so for instance of course it needs to
learn that fineness is a good level to
change strength because that's the one
we're optimizing with but if stuff pops
out that has been used or has been known
by cement engineers for a while like
titanium dioxide reduces the strength or
three calcium silicate increases
strength that's great because it really
gives us the confidence that the model
learns something meaningful
but we learned what is more important
than the model excel itself is actually
proper preprocessing so you should do
outlier filtering make sure to remove
extreme values because usually
extreme values mean it's a measurement
error but do not remove two extreme
values because they might actually teach
your machine learning uh a valuable
lesson um to figure out what's a good
threshold when to remove one that's a
good place for a hyper parameter
optimization
and also it's important to do proper
scaling our variables live on very
different scales so normalization is key
we used the robust scalar to do that but
we had to learn that the default
settings of the robust scalar are not
at robust the default settings are
scaling between the 25th and a 75th
percentile problem is if you have a data
dimension that has in the majority of
the data almost no variation but lots of
stuff is going on in the extreme ranges
using the default robust scalar would
really blow up that dimension so if you
scale between the 5th and the 95th
percentile you actually get to to our
mind a more robust robust scalar and
from now on we will use that as as a
default setting then of course we need
to do imputation
meaning because we have problems with
many missing values from experiments and
from from the measurement devices
but proper imputation also means just
throw away data that has too many
missing values because if you try to
impute these
you will end up with heavy bias in your
final machine learning pipeline
but this is already a nice step where
you can already use machine learning to
impute some columns because our columns
are highly co-linear so we might be able
to predict column a from column b and c
however still do simple imputation like
a group media and four columns that have
many missing features because uh if you
would again use machine learning here
you would introduce bias into your model
um when to do which of the three um and
defining thresholds again a good place
for a hyper parameter optimization
okay so now we have our model in place
um and we are soon to deploy the model
to actually run stuff in a cement plant
and optimize cement manufacturing
so of course before we deploy our model
we really want to know and get a good
estimate of how
well the model is going to behave in
this real-life setting so realistic
model evaluation is key
um so
in order to estimate the model
performance in the real life what you
can always do is cross validation the
problem is the assumption of
cross-validation of random regular
cross-validation is that your data is
independent
in a real-life setting especially in the
process industry like cement that is not
the case we have a constant stream of
material where we eventually take
samples so our data is highly highly
correlated in time i mean you can see
that here if i draw a high strength
sample today
then it's quite likely that tomorrow i
will also draw a high strength sample so
data is really highly correlated and the
ordering of data when it was taken
really matters so we cannot do
random cross validation because that
would yield huge data leakage so what we
do have to do instead is temporal cross
validation meaning we order our data
according to the time dimension and then
we train on a consecutive interval
followed by another consecutive interval
which we then use for validation but
even that wouldn't be enough for us
because remember the arrival of the true
labels the actual cement strength takes
28 days because i have to form a
concrete cube let it harden for 28 days
and then crush it and
this we had to bake in into the cross
validation meaning we have to skip data
for 28 days before we actually start the
validation full to really make our cross
validation resemble what's going on in
real life in real cement plans and if we
wouldn't do that and just use regular
random cross validation we would
actually overestimate mobile performance
by 30 and more and there's nothing more
embarrassing for a machine learning
engineer than figuring out later that
your model deployed in production is
much much worse from what you estimated
from your training data
okay so now we can use temporal cross
validation to measure realistic kpis
like mean squared error root mean
squared error i mean absolute error you
name it so for instance here you see
the simulation like one temporal cross
validation of one particular model over
one year prediction in red and true
labels in blue um the rule the mean
absolute error here is 1.4 megapascals
so
that then this leaves you is that good
is that bad what does 1.4 megapixels an
error actually mean so we need a way to
really figure out how our model behaves
with and compare it to something
meaningful and what you can always do is
compare for instance measures like the
mean squared error to the target
variance like the variance in the actual
target you're predicting and that's an
analog to r squared so it basically
tells you how much of the variance in my
target is actually explained by my
machine learning model
however that's a bit of difficult of a
measure because the variance of the data
we're looking at really depends on the
selected time frame so for instance if i
actually compare them or evaluate my
model only over a short amount of time
uh like this down here i only observe at
like a small variance in the target
variable because our data is highly
correlated also if i choose a larger
window i might get a larger variance in
the actual target variable and in fact
because we have a non-stationary process
it doesn't converge for infinite time
windows also we don't have infinite time
windows um so
if you evaluate models of a particular
time frame uh you have to be aware that
i can't compare model performances if i
normalize it by the target variants
over different time frames so if i
choose one year i have to stick with one
year and it doesn't make sense to
compare it with evaluations of half a
year or even shorter time scales but in
order to get rid of this
assumption or this problem of choosing a
time frame what you can always do is
compare your model performance to simple
bass lines so you should always use
simple bass lines and
a first natural choice of simple bass
line is always a linear model
still our nilia model has quite some
assumptions because we still need to do
pre-processing for the linear models so
that means we need to bake in
assumptions for scaling imputation and
of course
make a choice of features
and here's one advantage when you have
highly correlated data in time
there's a very easy way to come up with
a very simple baseline that has
basically no assumptions baked in and
that's just using a rolling median or a
rolling mean over a certain time frame
or the last x samples and then you have
a baseline that has no assumptions apart
from just the window size or the number
of samples
and if you can't even if your machine
learning even can't beat this rolling
media it's probably not worth applying
machine learning to it so that's a very
very nice baseline for settings like
these
so
this was already a lot of machining but
we quickly figured out that machine
learning is only the tip of the iceberg
um so this is our machine learning code
and this is all the rest and i mean i
took this from
hidden technical depth and machine
learning which is a great paper and i
think this picture popped up
during pi data already quite a lot but
it's it's so true right so for us about
two uh two full-time employees worked
about two months on the machine learning
code and now there's seven hats and
counting working three years and
counting on all the rest i mean for
instance there's lots of configuration
for us we have many different machine
learning models per customer we
have different machine learning models
per compressive strength for different
grouping softwares and all of this
somehow needs to be managed and then of
course there's lots of work going into
the serving infrastructure i mean our
models are dockerized and then served on
aws fargate or kubernetes and that needs
to be built and maintained and of course
there's loads of monitoring like
monitoring if just the application runs
if the machine learning models are
running if they are any good if data is
coming in if the data is any good and so
on and so forth
and here a big thank you uh to our
machine learning league nico who
actually replicated that image
from our code base in gitlab and you can
see it actually fits quite well so up
here is the model code including by the
way the feature transformations and
feature extractions and here
is all the rest yeah so way more than
the actual machine learning model
okay so i told you that there's lots of
monitoring and we do need lots of
monitoring because it turns out running
machine learning on customer provided
data is really hard
because customer data can change so for
instance there might be changes in the
data format i mean this happens why not
change a date right from european to
american or that's my favorite using
full stop and comma as decimal
separators almost unpredictably i mean
one is the english notation for decimals
the other one is the german one why not
mix both for fun
but there might actually be changes to
the data itself
so there might be humans in the loop
that are prettifying the data meaning i
mean some of the experiments like a
compressive strength experiment where
you actually have to crush the cube are
quite manual and sometimes humans tend
to if they get a measure that is uh not
in their favor slightly correct the
number uh to make it look prettier
problem is if you do that this will
really confuse machine learning so
here's like lots of advocating and
teaching involved that
that processes like this really have to
stop once you start deploying machine
learning and uh what regularly happens
is that there's a recalibrations of the
devices that provide the data frost like
the x-ray diffrectomy or x-ray
fluorescence i mean cement is a very
fine powder so stuff gets dirty pretty
quickly or gets clogged so you need to
replace parts and then recalibrate
devices and this then can cause
huge data and concept drifts and we need
to detect these and actually react upon
that and then there might actually be
problems with uh the sample sites so
where the samples are drawn
itself so as i told you there are
samples drawn right after the cement
modes these are the ones that we use to
make the predictions and actually steer
the cement mill grinding and however
there are also samples taken at the
delivery silo when the cement before the
cement gets shipped to the concrete
customers and these are usually the ones
that have compressive strength tests
attached to it so these are the ones
that have the true labels
that we can use for training and these
ones are used for prediction or
inference
and it could be that due to the physical
properties of this sample side and that
sample side they might be not completely
representative and there might be slight
shift for instance in the particle size
distribution so we have to know about
this and then bake that into our models
so there's lots of stuff that can
actually go wrong with data
so for that we actually introduced
like very sophisticated data science
processes whenever we onboard customer
and once after we have onboarded them so
for every new customer what we do is
what we call a data deep dive so that's
they send us historic data of three to
four years um and we really go through
each and every measurement of each and
every cement one by one and look at
idiosyncrasies and problems and whether
the data makes sense and if we spot
something that looks out of the ordinary
we go back to the customer and together
try to figure out what went wrong in the
plant or what happened in the plant at
that point in time that could explain
the shifts in the data
and then when we decided okay the data
looks feasible for machine learning and
it makes sense to actually apply it
then we can start integrating into the
systems of our customers and our
customers are cement plants and they are
not i.t companies meaning they have
quite some legacy systems in place and
integrating into legacy systems
is quite some work so usually that takes
about half a year
so and then once we finally have a
customer in production it doesn't stop
there of course so we need to do
continuous monitoring of
customers data so if there's data drifts
or shifts occurring or if if something
changes
other changes and then of course we need
to do continuous evaluation of all our
machine learning models
and i'm not kidding we have with each
and every customer weekly meetings where
we discuss machine learning and data
issues and changes in the plan because
as i told you if they recalibrate a
device or if they built a new mill or if
they changed a silo setting we need to
know about this
so
and this then brings me basically to my
final lesson that we had to draw from
this so machine learning as a service is
not necessarily or completely equivalent
to software as a service i mean software
as a service from a vc
point of view
is a great business opportunity because
usually you have high profit margins and
your marginal costs are zero with
increasing customer size and that's
unfortunately not so much the case for
machine learning as a service um because
i would argue that there's no such thing
as a minimum viable product in
industrial machine learning i mean to
really get like a basic machine learning
pipeline in place that can steer cement
there's so much we already have to do
and that is integrating into our
customers
plant to actually do data monitoring
this data is properly exported from
there we have to configure the machine
learning we of course have to train it
and deploy it and then run all the
predictions and optimizations and then
have means
in order to serve that back into the
plan so i would argue that in industrial
machine learning you don't start with a
skateboard but you actually always have
to start with a bike or even a full
full-fledged motorcycle
and then the other thing is
because we have machine learning models
per customer our ml costs scale
rather linearly with the number of
customers so no zero marginal cost also
not to mention all the machine learning
engineers you have to pay in order to
build and maintain that so um and i told
you there's loads of consulting and
educating involved
because our customers are like so to say
first time users of machine learning um
and so what you really need are key
account managers that are
a-skilled interacting with the customer
so they need to speak their language
they need to know about cement but they
also need to be knowledgeable about
machine learning because there's many
many questions coming up and of course
the number of key account managers also
not scales sublinearity with the number
of customers that you have so
with all this um we actually came to the
conclusion that in order to turn this
into a
viable business we have to hunt
elephants or hopefully whales but for
now elephants meaning these are
customers who are willing to pay about
uh a hundred thousand us dollars a year
um uh because uh otherwise it really
don't make sense to put industrial
machine learning into uh
fortunately cement customers are of that
kind uh but one challenge of course is
nobody gives away um this amount of
money lightly so uh negotiations and
sales processes might take some time so
like half a year a year or longer so you
need to be in for the long haul
and
that pretty much
concludes my talk thank you very much
for having me
here are some key takeaways from
from my slides
i'm
reachable on slack afterwards and in
gather so if you want to gather at the
cosy fireplace uh meet me up there and
if we i think we still have some time
left so i also happy to take some
questions here
are there questions in the q a
yes okay let me see
uh how do you exactly blend linear
regression in a
random forest um we use a random forest
uh correcting the errors of the linear
model works uh super nicely
um okay same question again
uh what software do you use to generate
the vis release of the ml models uh dash
plotly dash dash is great
um
could you elaborate more on there's no
mvp in industrial ml yes so the problem
is of course that um
there
is i mean loads of stuff that you
know
that you really need to implement i mean
it's not that you can come up with a
jupiter notebook um with just some
historic data and show that to your
customers and then say hey look um
there's my machine learning model
because there are there's nothing
actionable from that so in order to
really have actionable ml that changes
something in the plan
you have to be fully integrated into the
plan so like this whole control loop
needs to be closed and
that's quite a lot of work
um
yeah did you manage to incorporate the
knowledge of employers of your customers
in order to improve your models yes um
so our pre-processing pipeline is
actually quite sophisticated um so it's
not just uh scaling imputation and
outlier filtering
there is for instance
encoding of different situations in the
plant and there are data transformations
like some ratios that actually make
sense from uh and cement engineering uh
cement quality engineering perspective
okay i think i run out of time here but
thank you very much thanks for having me